رفاق نعم فيتنام
وسط الأشجار المحطمة بالقذيفة
تكتشف القوات الأوكرانية كيف تقربنا من
المكاسب الجديدة التي تحققت بشق الأنفس حول الوحل الخلفي
يذهب ورائي مسافة خمسة أمتار وهو
يتجه أخيرًا إلى
أي مدى بعيدًا عن الخطوط الروسية هنا
أمتار أقرب
ما هي الدروس هنا
هجوم أوكرانيا المضاد الأكبر الذي طال انتظاره ، يمكنك أن ترى هنا كيف
تجف الأرض كيف كانت رطبة
من قبل ومدى صعوبة
مرور المركبات المدرعة على أرض
المعركة يتغير الآن الصيف
القادم
وهذا كل شيء
للرد.  - هجومية ،
لذلك علينا أن نذهب أسرع قليلاً هنا
لأنهم يأخذون الكثير من النيران القادمة
هنا ،
نعم ،
إن لم يكن للحرب ، فسيكون هناك
غطاء صغير رائع هنا من القصف ، اذهب إلى
الطائرة بدون طيار بشكل خاطئ ، سنأتي إلى هنا
لأنك  لقد سمعنا صوت طائرة بدون طيار أعلاه ، لذلك
لدينا بعض الغطاء هنا ، ونأمل ألا ترانا
هنا
نقترب أكثر من الممرات الروسية ،
هذا الخندق واحد من عدة خندق وحقل
ألغام جديد تم وضعه لصد
القوات الروسية على بعد حوالي 600 متر من
هجوم مضاد بعيدًا عن الأنظار في الشمال
والجنوب من هنا ، المزيد من القوات الأوكرانية
تتقدم بالبناء على المكاسب الأخيرة
هنا يقول حلفاء أوكرانيا الغربيون إن
تشكيل العمليات
للهجوم المضاد الكبير جاري بالفعل
هنا لن يقول القادة هنا ما إذا كان هذا
جزءًا من ذلك  الهجوم المضاد لكن
المكاسب التي حققوها في الخلف هي
دفعة معنوية هائلة للقوات الأوكرانية
ولكن كيف تشعر عندما تكون في المعركة
الآن وبالنسبة لها في الواقع بعد كل هذا
الوقت الذي استولت على المزيد من الأراضي ،
فأنا أحب ذلك حقًا.  لأنني
مع عائلتي مع الرجال الذين يمثلون
عائلتي ولكن النجاح ليس كل تلك
الشهية المتعرقة للنصر والتي تتزايد
الفظائع الروسية التي تغذي الغضب ، فنحن جميعًا
نريد فقط استعادة أراضينا واستعادة
Killa أقصى قدر ممكن من الروس ، يمكننا أن نعتقد أن
الروس يفهمون
أنه لا  لا أعتقد أنهم
سيقتلون جميعًا ، ستكون
معركة صعبة بالنسبة لك رغم ذلك ، نعم
أيضًا ، لكننا مستعدون لذلك ، إنها أرضنا
لأننا نغادر ، وهناك انفجارات أكثر
من هذا
لا نطلبه  نحن فقط نركض ونستمر في
الجري ،
نسمع طائرة بدون طيار ، لذلك نحن نركض ، لقد
جهزوا ناقلة الجنود المدرعة الخاصة بهم ،
نعم ، نعود الآن إلى
الطائرات بدون طيار فوق المزيد من المدفعية القادمة ،
إنها معدات سوفيتية قديمة أكثر
دروع الناتو الحديثة مشغولة في مكان آخر في
ساحة المعركة